this is a new turntable from TDK it has
an aluminum frame with an acrylic top
all of the components on it are machined
aluminum they're all colored gold so it
looks really cool
you've got the tonearm the controls for
the speed it's a belt drive turntable
the belt actually runs around the
outside of the platter which is very
cool so you can see the belt moving it
comes with a little spindle so you can
play your 45s and it comes to the slip
mat the platter itself is also gold
aluminum it also comes with a diamond
tip stylus that fits into the tonearm
the Turin arm also takes any aftermarket
stylus so if you have one you're prefer
to use it has a built-in phono preamp
inside of it so you don't need a photo
amp inside of your head unit and your
stereo to use it you just run regular
RCA line level outputs into your stereo
for it it's $400 with a built-in USB
port it also comes with software so you
can transfer your vinyl albums to mp3s
and if you don't want the USB port you
can get it for $300 it's not a DJ
turntable because it's a belt drive as
opposed to a direct drive turntable but
it is a high quality unit it's meant
mostly to look good and to sound good
sitting on top of your stereo and look
especially good with this really nice
custom leather dust cover that comes
with it and it comes out in March
you